Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
This is real.
A guy hold on the like the one 800 number for that.
You know the accurate Jeffrey Dean Morgan sausages.
He has a 800 number where I guess people can leave a message.
I left him a message where he's really upset.
The size sauce,
Huh?
Gimme gimme
gimme
gimme gimme gimme
a little
more money.
Nicotine.
Now
you don't have it.
Well,
you've got white man that way.
Over a hundred times.
Take a 12 and a couple of the other night and I ain't going to work and I'm not
ever again.
And it's hard.
I don't eat that.
Don't meet gimme gimme gimme
gimme
gimme gimme gimme
gimme come late.
Oh,
amazing.
Yeah.
Paid money.
They have money.
Michael and sage.
That was a Ramsey.
We always have fucking,
we definitely have,
I mean,
that's Ramsay McQueen with a Jimmy Dean.
I like how he hates the maple and sage.
I hate that shit to do.
You do.
He's,
he's saying that that's a,
that's a northern,
yeah,
that's a northern uppity.
Well,
he right about that.
Yeah.
I don't like fancy either.
I agree.
You know,
I don't like
that gay shit.
Oh,
I agree.
I don't think that gay shit either.
And you know,
and even as trader's Joe,
they have these fancy fucking sausages like chicken and dilly with the chunks
apple in there.
It's fucking nasty dude.
Nasty,
nasty.
Like you gotta be so nasty all the time.
I agree.
I like just like,
I want it to salty in Greece and then I don't like that.
The road,
the herbs and the Natha
classics now kind of makes me feel like,
oh,
the board is bad.
Finally.
I know.
God Damn,
we've been
AA being leg you like mile back
someone.
Yay.
Yay Back.
It's back,
man.
Yeah.
I feel like,
I feel like it's a long time.
We,
oh my God.
I feel like my dog is back from the groomers.
No,
we had the sound engineer come in and we had a great guy,
Scott came and uh,
oddly enough new this space isn't that bananas really create the story.
So I was at flappers doing shows and Scott comes up to me and he goes,
hey,
he's,
he works at flappers.
Right?
He goes,
hey,
just see a,
just,
you know,
I know the person who owned the house before you.
I know that studio.
I'm the sound engineer that worked for the guy that owned the compose.
Beautiful music composed.
Yeah.
Like scored so many movies in this room.
I couldn't believe it.
I could,
he gave me his card and I immediately gave it too.
Cause I know we've been having issues and Gourd,
wonderful music to beautiful films.
And now you guys are like,
yeah.
So yeah,
you gave me his contact.
Yeah,
I called him and he came out here and he helped solve the mystery.
God Damn.
Yeah.
Now wait,
hold on.
Back to this meat flavored meet discussion.
Now the one caveat,
uh,
yeah.
Okay,
now you're just showing off because in the last episode I had a really big burp.
Okay.
I'm a really big bite.
So now here's my one thing I like and have really big bite.
I really like,
uh,
I like whole foods seasoned to bacon that we'd been getting lately.
Yeah,
that's really good.
They have the Jalapeno garlic.
It's unbelievable now that they do at home.
[inaudible] that's what they do right there at the butcher.
Does it,
I don't know if they do it right there cause sometimes I don't have it.
And I ask them,
where's the flavored bacon?
And then he says,
well we have the bacon in the back,
but we haven't seasoned it yet.
And I go,
oh fucking chop chop bro.
Yeah,
get on it dude.
I got you.
Got,
you got time to fucking put on that hat.
You can't fucking season the bacon.
Well,
now that I got a 12 year old girl to feed,
I've got a heavy scotch woman.
I noticed that that guy kept saying the name wrong.
It's
Jeffrey Dean Morgan,
right?
Sausages.
Jeffrey Dean Morgan.
Yeah.
You're in a awfully good mood today.
Why is that?
Oh No.
Why is that Bobby?
I Dunno,
Trish,
was it Trish last night or Karen that came out?
Oh No,
it was,
uh,
Trish night.
Yeah.
How do you know the difference now between,
uh,
she doesn't take a lot.
Karen and Trish does shut back a lot to figure it out more with Trish.
Girl was out.
Hey.
Hey,
did you wire tap our rooms?
Yeah.
It was fun.
Gosh,
it was fun.
You're like,
you know,
you're a p I g I had to get fucked up.
You know,
I had to drink a whole bottle of Thunderbird and then I can do it with you.
It was okay.
Oh,
Ooh.
I want to love you.
P.
I g pretty young pig.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It was that,
is that what that song was about?
I want to love u p.
I.
G.
Yeah,
that's what it's about.
Should we do a proper show open?
Oh yeah.
Deputy Dean.
No,
my boards back.
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
have you got a bad bite?
Got a bad back and bite.
All right,
here we go.
Show is rolling.
Let's do this.
Sound good or bad?
Bite
bleeding all over my vagina.
All over this.
So get the fuck off so I can get off the plane.
Well,
welcome to your mom's house.
Christina.
Pushes.
It's interesting.
It's really good.
The base,
uh,
real
quick before I forget,
a lot of people enjoyed and then a lot of people complained about the live
podcast that went up.
No boy.
Um,
here's what I can tell you,
man.
I had no problem playing it on.
I,
I listened to it on the podcast APP on my phone.
Sounded totally normal.
Um,
wasn't to it on iTunes.
Sounded totally normal to me and I noticed that all the comments were back and
forth.
I mean,
would it be like you can't hear it and the next person would say you can hear it
fine.
Here's all I can tell you.
Um,
it's the file that we got from them and I've sent it now,
which is I guess too late,
but I sent it to another engineer to see if they can do some type of treatment
on it,
see if they can fix it and I'll re upload it.
I'm waiting on that answer also for the late show with Yoshi.
So if they can,
if they can,
you know,
make it any better,
I'll,
I will gladly pay for that.
And then upload it.
Then,
um,
that's,
that's where it's at.
I,
I had got so many messages that said it's fine and then the other people would
be like,
it's not,
I can't hear a thing.
I don't know what to tell you.
So it's weird that that many people are,
you know,
having conflicting issues with it.
But who knows?
Jean,
I don't know what to tell you.
I have to wait.
We'll just wait.
We'll just see.
Gosh,
I'm so thirsty.
Let me see if I have my water.
Oh,
I do.
It's right here.
It's called liquid.
Not as good as evo.
So much better than CVS.
You may have noticed I sabotaged your CV and I put in all the qual.
I did notice.
Wait till you see with arriving at the house later though,
that shit,
it is the mother lode of z.
Where do you even get these disgusting drinks?
Over 80 cans coming.
Shut the front door.
Where do you get them?
On Amazon.
Yeah.
Using your mom's house,
podcasts.
Dotcom,
banner.
Click on it.
Disgusting ass flavors.
Did you get?
Um,
I learned,
I realized that I didn't,
I'm not as in the grape,
so,
oh,
one thing I like my favorite ones.
The cream soda.
That's okay.
Oh,
I liked that one.
I got the Black Cherry tree and I got some doctors.
Eve.
Yes.
I do like the grape though.
I wish you to up that.
Great.
Okay.
I didn't know you never mentioned it.
You were always like,
oh yeah,
so that's why I didn't do it.
If you would have said it,
I would've done it.
I want to squish your balls like that video.
We,
boy,
we've been watching that a lot.
So to everybody too.
I sent it to Ron.
I haven't talked to him on in a year and he just sent me one of those,
uh,
was a Gif is actually Jif,
but yeah.
Yeah.
You're supposed to say Jeff,
but I swear to you who's saying that the guy that invented that code,
well then he should have put a jug.
A Jay.
Yeah.
Jay.
I APP is a Jif Gif is GI.
If we learned this on fucking sesame street,
I'm not debating it.
I just know that read all about the discussion about it and,
and it basically is like,
it's 100% Jeff,
but the world has said fuck you to his request.
So yeah.
Well,
okay,
then again,
I,
you know,
I should have been in a j tell,
you're like,
well,
you know,
I got to tell you.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's like you're going to demand that we all say it the wrong way.
It's a,
it's a irrational want.
Sorry,
I don't know your fucking Pronoun.
You know what I mean?
He's demanding.
I call,
I call him Zinzer and I don't even know it.
I don't want,
you know,
by the way,
he's fucking cunts.
Okay.
What with the video?
We haven't talked about the video.
We'll video that.
We've been watching.
Stop.
Let's not get off track too,
right?
You're right,
you're right.
But don't forget,
put a,
put a pin in it.
As they say in the corporate world,
like Mike,
we'll circle back later.
Circle back.
Think outside the box if you don't mind.
And
God damn,
I hate all that stuff.
It's so oppressive.
So my Cronin's sent me this,
you know,
the ten second video and I opened it and it's shows an apartment complex on fire
and you're like,
oh,
okay,
what's going to happen here?
And then it jump cuts to a lady kicking a guy in the balls naked and then
punching him in the balls and then,
and then kneeing him in the balls and then it ends with her grabbing his ball
and lifting him up by them.
And they're enormous.
But it's also edited to Jitterbug by Wham.
It'll wake me up before you go.
Yeah Dude,
a bug,
right.
Wake me up.
Um,
and they also add the editing is phenomenal.
And then when she grabs his balls and lift him up,
it's when the horn goes.
So it matches that.
Yeah.
Great.
It's really great.
We can't play it on the show because the audio gets flagged,
the video will get flagged,
everything gets fucking flagged.
Fucking flags,
flags,
flag in your ass.
Tell him they tell him,
but I can't get over is the perfect music that goes with it.
And how large that man's balls are.
His balls.
I'm sure we've talked about this before.
I'm not against anyone's kinks.
I'm like,
whatever gets you going,
how do you not vomit if you're a guy like women don't understand this.
I mean,
our son has just stepped on my balls and I'm like,
oh my God,
and like double over and this guy has multiple punches,
kicks.
I'm saying,
forget if you like it.
How does your body not just shut down?
I don't understand.
Hey,
maybe we should ask if you could,
if you like getting your balls kicked and anybody out there like that.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
How do you deal with the pain?
How do,
how does your body not shut down?
And I'm also amazed at the size of those man's balls at the end.
They're huge.
I've never seen balls in real life,
but I mean one hates you once with one of those.
I'm telling you 99% of the population really is shut down
in voluntarily.
Shut down.
You're not going.
I think I should not you physically,
you can feel it up inside like your kidneys,
your you're,
you're lowered his house.
It feels like when you get kicked in the balls,
it's usually a delay.
It's like you get hit,
not what you respond to.
It's a moment later and you,
I mean you feel nauseated.
You know what I mean?
You get hit hard enough.
Yeah.
You want to vomit your,
your eyes roll.
It's a pain.
That's the key.
It's just aches everywhere.
It's,
it's,
it's horrible.
It's scared me.
Yeah.
That's what it feels right now.
The pain of it.
It's the worst.
I can't tell you how bad it is,
but here's my thinking is that maybe they're not as affected by the pain.
I think they have to be there.
There has to be something different about somebody that signs up for that.
Maybe that's like they don't have that much of a reaction to what you can't.
I mean I'm telling you,
forget getting hit a grace for a lot of good.
For me.
I'm the,
I'm that guy where like if,
if it was like someone had a backpack and swung it around and it just graze my
balls,
I have to sit down and kind of gather,
gather myself before,
you know,
I wouldn't just walk away.
I've got hold on a second would take,
it would take like a minute to respond and she's,
she lines up her fist punches,
kicks him
knees,
full knees.
And then,
and then the two handers,
my favorite,
cause it looks like she's pulling like a,
like a turnip out of the ground like that.
And it does look exactly like that.
Right.
And then his balls are like grapefruits.
I mean I'm never seen balls that big and I,
I keep watching cause I liked that.
The finale,
I don't really like saying guys get hurt.
That's not why I laugh.
I laugh at,
I laugh at the size of that guy's nuts and how hard she's pulling.
And then you go,
who's into this?
Like this is such a weird kink man calling on.
Yeah.
Okay.
Would you rather it's pup play?
For your sexual outlet.
You've only to the sexuality of pup play or getting your nuts kicked.
Well,
does my pup play?
Is it only with guys or can I have a woman there?
Because you're heterosexual.
I will make an allotment for a woman to be there.
Both cases.
Now you'll get to have,
excuse me,
sex in both scenarios,
but before you do the foreplay is either pup play or aggressive ball kicking?
Yes.
Oh,
it's
100% I'm a fucking dog.
I'd eat out of a dog bowl and take me on walks.
I'll piss in the backyard.
You grow a tail,
you can put eight dildos in my ass before I sign up for ball kicking
potato patato you know,
I mean,
I would be first of all,
after one of those kicks,
100% it's nine one
ambulance there.
Immediate,
the amber lamps,
amber lamps lamp.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
One of them.
You can't really survive.
I feel like,
I mean,
look,
nature nature's protecting those nuts that nature's telling you,
hey,
don't fuck with what's in here.
What's in here is very important stuff.
Precious cargo.
I mean,
first of all,
you shouldn't get hit like that in any part of your body,
right.
It's supposed to.
It's not cool to sign up for a bleeding.
You know that part that's the most vulnerable part of the man's body.
Easily.
Yeah.
Why don't you ask someone to stab you in the eyes,
you know?
See if that does that feel good to fucking idiot.
God so stirred all,
yeah,
all of it.
All that stuff makes me laugh.
Like all the violence,
sexual fetishes like clamping nipples and like,
yeah.
It's so funny.
It's funny and we talked about this last night after Bobby and Karen mates we
love is the like,
who's got the fucking time?
How do you have time to develop these fetishes?
Find out that's what you look like.
I mean,
most people don't have that kind of,
I don't got that kind of time having a baby and stuff like,
Hey,
guess what?
I like to have my nuts kicked butt this certain way and I like to have her pull
them at the very end.
Like the job man.
Hey,
how do you know you like that fucking,
yeah,
you got to go deep on that stuff.
Like that's not a random discovery.
No,
and especially because society will make you repress those desires a lot.
Those,
those are great.
Those are,
those are deeply repressed sexual fantasies by the way.
So you really got to go deep.
You've got to take time away.
We really should be celebrating it.
But of course this does not being,
you know,
ashamed but,
but the time investment,
it's like going to therapy.
You've got to go down,
down into the layers and figure out.
But you know what I need is a slow thing.
Like maybe it is a thing where the guy goes,
no,
what about this?
Like what if he realizes he likes to be dominated so he signs up for that,
right?
And then okay,
that goes well no.
And there's like a little bit of spanking,
right?
Or like whipping or something.
Clinton nipple clamping and he's like,
oh,
it's painful.
I like it.
And that slowly gets to like a little ball smack or something.
Like she's hitting him and then inadvertently grazes is nuts.
And was like,
oh that hurts.
But I like that next time.
Why don't you go ahead and step that up a little bit.
But again,
at the time
I've seen a video of a high heels like this to let appeals where that stomps on
dicks and balls.
It makes me laugh every time.
No,
no,
no.
But that like it hurts.
He'll like that hoof.
Yeah.
That's really,
that's,
that's really something man.
Yeah,
it's intense.
I don't know if I could,
I,
you know,
it's funny cause you and I,
once we put a baby jeans down for the night,
you've got to maybe,
maybe a two hour window before you have to go to bed again and wake up at six in
the morning with the kids.
So it's like,
ah,
Shit.
In my world,
in our world,
it's like we just got to,
you know,
Bobby and carrying gotta go quick and then go to bed.
Yeah.
And there's no time for fantasy,
you know,
ball play in pup play and all that crap,
man.
I mean,
you gotta put your depth for your time.
Glen,
what's your ass?
Smells like coconut bowls.
Right.
This is single people.
Shit.
That's a time commitment.
Yeah.
This is single dudes.
And also to learn what they smell like.
Got,
damn.
You really is talking about,
you know,
Rhett repetition.
Yeah.
It's a practice.
It's a technique.
You got to,
you got to really dedicate yourself to pup play.
Oh yeah.
You can't just be like a casual pop player.
No,
no,
no.
That's,
it's really a commitment,
you know,
run your finger along the crack of your ass.
You don't need to finger your whole,
you don't want to come back with shit on your finger.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
The fact that he has to tell,
I don't think he has to tell people that.
Do you think he really needed to?
Uh,
yes.
I think he did need to.
I think,
I think some of those pups were like,
oh,
finger it,
and he had to,
he,
he learns that like,
yeah,
you got to tell them over time and he's alone.
Don't,
don't go inside.
Gosh.
Yeah.
Because sometimes I feel like you don't need to be that specific with
directions,
but apparently you do.
Yeah.
No.
You gotta be,
you gotta be specific.
Do you want to see this lady flip out on a plane?
Oh yeah.
I like her.
I kind of,
here's the thing,
she's definitely overreacting,
but I do understand,
I do understand when it's like no one,
like a traveler,
a business traveler.
Some of you out there are busy travel.
There's no that feeling of like,
will you just get off the fucking plane?
Sometimes you're in the back and you're like,
wait,
are they loading in the next group of passengers?
Because I feel like we've been standing back here for 30 fucking minutes.
Yeah.
It is the most unnerving.
And then you get mad at those fucking dilettantes Sunday travelers.
Yeah,
I know who come with five loose bags.
Nothing is really tied together.
And then one thing is up here.
Another thing is,
and this asshole's taking hits their time.
You like to get your life bro.
And there's a,
my favorite is sometimes the person will put their bag in the overhead behind
where they sat.
Yeah.
Dummy.
Wait.
They'll go back and get it when you land and then they'll be like,
I'm up there.
They're like,
no.
Now you're back here.
Yeah.
You came back to get the bag.
She didn't get to go back to the,
what are you talking about?
W what you do is you put the bag before you sit down cause there's still more
overhead usually in the front.
Yeah,
but not first load.
Not at first.
I see people do that.
[inaudible] a real scopes.
They load the plane from back to front.
Most airlines with the exception of like southwest or whatever chaos that
fucking airline is.
Yeah.
So I always put mine in the row before,
right.
My coach Rowe or whatever the fuck I'm sitting if I'm on in first class.
So that way when you're on the way out,
you pick up your bag,
dip shit.
Don't put it back in the limit.
Limit Gray you and let me upgrade you to the hottest channels.
That was beyond saying,
I know she did direct TV commercial.
You believe that shit,
dude,
that's like Madonna upgrade you,
and she was like,
I'm going to upgrade you to the hottest channels on directv.
We couldn't believe that that was in 2000 like eight days old this year.
We got married,
we had our one luxury was cable TV and we would laugh at that.
I love it.
Yeah.
That's kind of starting.
It's almost like she's talking to herself.
Sure.
She has her headphones on.
I think she might be listening to music.
I feel what this guy looks like here in a moment is how I feel all the time.
Whenever I see crazy.
Yeah.
Like that
to that guy.
See how he's,
he's covering his face.
It's like when you're cringing for someone.
That's how I feel most of the time in life when somebody speaks a more like
that's such a,
you know,
you do that face a lot.
Yeah.
You've done that with me if a lot with you.
What do you mean?
Just like,
oh,
yesterday we were at Neiman Marcus.
We were in there buying socks for Yale and I was like,
there's these stupid plastic shorts.
What,
you got to set that up differently though?
Because you were doing a bit,
you were doing a bit and maybe a laugh.
I'm talking about when someone's serious,
that's when I'm embarrassed to you is what I'm usually trying to make you laugh.
I'm public.
And then you go,
oh my God.
Yeah,
that was,
yeah.
So here's what happened.
Um,
we,
we have a lunch coming up and we're going to dress nice.
So I had to,
I was like,
oh,
I'll,
I'll dress nice then,
but I don't think I have any,
I don't know where they are.
Dressed socks,
you know.
So I was like,
let's stop.
And the,
we're at the country club,
the up in the,
uh,
one of the department stores and buy a dress socks.
Neiman forecast is,
is like,
I mean,
it is outrageous as far as that is like a couture store and other words like,
hi,
and who buys that stuff?
Super,
super expensive designer designers should like,
it's her dad's only a few that are in that company.
I feel like,
you know,
most people know that you go to Macy's and then you step up to Bloomingdale's or
whatever and,
and then you know,
it goes,
it goes on up.
But like Neiman Marcus is like,
it's like shirts,
shirts and stuff.
Yeah,
it's really crazy.
So anyways,
that's about,
I'm comfortable,
right?
Some of the stuff there,
but then they always have the range.
I know there's a one that I went into,
I was in Beverly Hills one time after a meeting and I needed,
I forget what a belt or something.
And so I went into the ones that are on Wilshire there a Barney's,
oh fuck.
A Barney's.
Barney's has like $5,000 sweatshirts and you're like,
oh,
buy this.
Who would wear a $5,000 sweatshirt?
You know?
Even if we had millions of dollars,
if we had bill gates money,
there's nothing on earth that justifies,
in my opinion,
a $5,000 shirt.
No,
of course not unethical.
It's fucking bananas to even spend that much on a tee shirt.
Crazy.
I know that would have to be your worries.
Like you'd have to work in fashion to be justify something like this.
A fucking nothing.
Anyways,
there's a whole,
the have like normal high end clothes and then there's a whole section of just
designer nonsense where you're like,
who the fuck would wear this?
And I was buying,
I was paying for my socks or hair of blacks,
which by the way,
they're dressed socks were at least the ones I bought were normally priced.
Oh they were like $16,
which I is socks.
I know,
but I'm saying for that store I was always expecting it to be something crazy to
anyways you go.
And we were making fun of um,
some of the clothes like on the phone and the guy noticed by the way,
cause we take pictures of each other holding up their clothes.
Um,
well good cause he,
he knows it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I put it on Instagram.
A picture of me in a picture of you.
Yeah.
And Yeah,
he noticed.
But anyways,
so we're by,
he goes,
I saw you looking at,
and it was actually called something jeans.
It was like Ruby's jeans.
And I was like,
yeah,
he goes,
you didn't strike me as the type of guy that would wear that.
And I was like,
oh yeah I wasn't.
And then he's checking me out and you go,
Hey Tom,
how about these?
And you held up like black,
what?
What was the material?
I go,
Gosh,
do you guys have like plastic shorts?
Do you guys have any plastic?
Because they look like they're made of like garbage bags,
but I want to pay like $400 for them.
And the guy,
I forget even what he says,
but that's when you started your hand went,
I was like,
God mom,
cause you also go,
you go seems breathable.
Especially in the summer.
Like you're saying like all this kind of passive aggressive insulting stuff.
And I'm like,
um,
the lady picked up on it too.
She goes,
she goes,
they're actually really comfortable.
We're like,
okay sure.
Uh,
who's buying the plastic shorts in the summertime?
These crazy person answered it is absurd and it's expensive and yeah,
whatever.
Anyways,
they um,
you know,
they have a laugh and I,
and then the guy kind of is like,
you know,
I go,
who does buy this as well?
He goes,
actually the guy,
the designer of that was here and he doesn't wear that shit guy.
The designer of this ridiculous clothes doesn't wear his clothes.
Right.
He
goes,
the designer is French by the way.
It's,
yeah,
it totally,
by the way,
all those clothes look like foreign cousin clothing.
Like my Hungarian relatives will be like,
this is great.
What nice glows.
There's like studs on it and red paint.
They would wear that.
It's all denim and like different colors the way you normally dressed to hungry
where they'd be like,
what are you wearing?
Yeah,
they think I'm a total peg.
They're always like,
oh genes,
all of his adding genes and they like to wear white pants a lot in the summer
and white shoes and I don't fucking rock.
I,
I never rocked the answer.
We took them to saddle ranch and they thought that was the best thing.
You see the cars drive by and they had,
they're tight.
They have those type white sneakers on that looked like their foot binding
shows.
European stocks did.
My year old.
They love.
Yeah,
they love autumn on the suit.
This is odd.
One is the best.
This is the best our money on Monday.
They love that shit.
Did,
I mean,
yeah,
it's flashy.
Flashy.
It's too flashy for Americans.
I bet you like a lot of tourists go in there and they buy that shit.
Like euro,
like my,
my lane,
like Ukrainian.
Basically in most circles in this country.
You would get your ass kicked for wearing that easily.
Yeah.
Dude,
you can't walk up in this place.
I mean you can't walk in and be like,
what?
Like I got these torrents studied,
spray painted Jean shorts on.
What's up and people would pick the fuck is wrong with you.
Yeah,
because we pulled the pair of Jorts yeah.
That were like painted on and studs and
studied jorts.
First of all,
if you're wearing shorts,
you're somewhere in the south.
Likely.
You know what I mean?
Like you're sitting on a trailer or something.
I think you don't,
you have a joke about dirt driveways and was like,
yeah,
you're on a,
you're on a dirt driveway.
Yes.
It's not a good look,
but don't dress up a George.
No,
the does casual.
The Jordan is by nature dressed down $800 easily,
dude,
high end fashion is enraging world.
When were like you are paying what?
Yeah.
Well cause I often just,
I like to look at that stuff and like Stella Mccartney,
she always has stuff and Neiman Marcus and I sometimes I like her stuff but I'm
like,
dude,
I can't pay,
I won't pay rather $1,500 for a pair of fucking sneakers with a dazzling on
them.
Man Who's doing this?
Who's supporting this nonsense.
I also think about that like how many people have to buy that to make that work?
Five.
No,
I'm saying more than make that line work,
so all those people are wearing this fucking thing.
I think in the case of like a Stella Mccartney,
she doesn't have to work for money.
It's one of those things where this is like my pet project.
The,
no daddy set
up the estate for me.
But a title,
don't you need a busy bunch of things that are like 100 bucks so that like a lot
of people can buy.
Right?
Like isn't there a line,
a lower tiered that regular people buy?
I'm assuming?
Yeah.
I don't know.
But when shoes are $1,000 I'm like,
oh my gosh,
we're sneakers.
That makes me particularly furious.
Yeah.
And like,
and I know a lot of sneaker heads and it's cool.
Like I love,
I have nothing but sneakers basically.
Yeah.
But I have like a major cap on that too.
Well what's your,
what's,
yeah,
I think $1,000 for Gucci sneakers is a crazy ridiculous,
I thought you were about to say is,
is that your cap?
I'm like way below,
way below that.
Uh,
cause we'd been in Gucci at the country club and I've been like,
who the fuck is buying this?
And it is,
it's all foreigners.
It's all like,
you know,
Asian,
whatever people are Saudi,
the Saudi princess.
It's here.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Visiting for the,
her summer room,
Springer,
whatever before she gets married or has a lot of money actually that that pours
in from,
from tourist stores.
Absolutely.
Like in Beverly Hills.
I mean it's not really,
it's not the locals who are shopping on Rodeo tourists.
Right.
There was that I went to,
we went to that restaurant and it's in a hotel there and that's what the guy
told me.
He goes,
oh,
he said it's so hot in the Middle East during the summer that they come here
where it's by the way hot,
he goes,
this is so much less hot that they'll come here.
They'll uh,
they'll stay in one of our,
like they'll run out of florists suites.
Wow.
For us for a couple months.
Shop,
shop,
fly back.
They love to shop.
Yeah.
And I heard it and I'm like,
we're talking about dozens and dozens of,
of groups of people doing this.
They all come together as a family and,
well I heard a story,
it's like the,
those Middle Eastern girls who are about 20 years old,
it's like their last hurrah before they get married.
Off or whatever.
They'll come to like Beverly hills.
Yeah,
and they'll come with their friends and their quote chaperones and they'll go to
Gucci,
Prada and they'll buy all the stuff that they can't wear back home and they'll
wear it out in the streets and we'll go night clubbing or whatever.
One time where?
Yup.
And then leave it behind.
Just thousands and thousands of,
they won't,
you can't take it back because they'll go,
you know,
mom and daddy or I'll see it or whatever.
Their customs,
I don't fucking know what the deal is,
but they don't take the clothing back.
That's,
that's where it all here.
And then put the fucking Burke on once they get back home.
Yeah,
I know the Chinese too.
They're like spending crazy money.
Yeah.
Great.
Let them shit.
Yeah.
Anyway,
I am buying,
you're fucking crazy.
Jorts for $800 someone has to
for Jorts.
They should give you those George.
They should be like,
will you take these?
Yeah.
You make your own.
George gave me $100.
I would take them,
but I wouldn't wear them.
I'd take him out for them.
You'd take him out?
Would you wear their lifespan?
Will you take these with you?
I'll be like,
I'll take,
I'm not
going to wear them.
What if that company hears this?
And they're like,
Tom,
I know you've got a Netflix buyers will coming up.
We're going to offer you here.
We out.
Huh?
$1 million to where the jorts and the cool shirt.
The gold.
No,
I won't do $1 million.
I would do it for the cover art.
That's my negotiating tool.
I'll do the cover art and your stupid outfit,
but I will not shoot my specs on it because of an outfit like that will change
your whole persona.
The people could watch what I'm talking.
No one would be like,
I,
they'd be like,
I heard you were talking,
but I didn't listen because I watched your jorts.
It's like Eddie is,
are doing standup and heals.
People were like,
wait,
this guy's wearing fucking heels.
Like,
so distracting.
Yeah.
Um,
well that's too bad.
You know,
maybe,
maybe we'll get a nice really expensive clothing line to sponsor your next
special.
No,
thank you.
I just want to fucking shirt.
Tee Shirt.
Same here.
Black.
Just wear black dude and timeless.
Black on black.
On black.
On black on murdered out there.
Yeah.
That's all you got to where you know,
and the older I get,
look,
this is as flashy as I go.
I'm wearing an Adidas old school run DMC.
Jane.
Yeah,
tracksuit tracksuit.
This is,
but this is my eastern bloc roots.
This is my euro trash stuff.
I like this,
but this is this flashy dude.
I'll a strictly black,
white,
gray.
I like solid colors.
Solid as you can tell.
Yeah.
I don't give no fuck God.
No,
I don't fuck with fashion.
I'm not,
I'm not a Fashionista.
No Doc.
I am like,
I like,
um,
if I had a job for it,
I would,
you know,
I would wear nice ties.
Yeah.
But I don't have a job but smell better than I used to.
All right,
let's go back to this lady losing her mind.
I'm in pain so I don't care who you are.
It sounds to me like,
you know,
me
dry the real,
that's one of those lines.
You can always pull on someone as a,
don't talk to me like,
you know me,
they,
that's a big line.
I'm on the Internet.
You don't know me.
You don't talk like you know him,
you know shit about me.
Yo,
one time,
one of the scary scary at my scariest la,
one of them La incident was,
um,
years ago,
this is when I was working,
uh,
I forget one of the most,
one of my morning,
you know,
uh,
postproduction jobs and I was at a gas station and silver lake,
it's like eight 30 in the morning rush hour traffic.
Everyone's in,
you know,
cars are flying by.
Anyways,
I'm filling up my tank and a car that's,
that had just,
I guess gotten gas rips through the parking lot,
like goes like she hates.
So all I did was I was,
I was putting gas in and I looked up and I went,
like,
I shook my head and then I go back to,
you know,
looking at the tank and then I hear it
and I look up
and the guy had reversed,
stopped right in front of me and he goes,
what's up dog?
And I go,
and it's a,
it's a goofy,
I kind of a goofy looking white guy with black hair and a like a bad thin black
mustache.
Like almost like it doesn't grow in hmm.
You know,
not almost,
it doesn't,
it doesn't grow in completely.
And it's kind of a,
uh,
tweaked out look in his eyes,
you know,
he goes,
what's up dog?
And I go,
what's up?
And he goes,
you acting like you know me homie.
And this is because I had gone like this,
like an eye roll.
Yeah.
I like rolled my eyes at him ripping through this parking lot.
And in that moment I remember with flashed through my head was like,
this guy doesn't seem like a capable,
tough guy or anything like that.
But in my head,
like this is like all happening,
obviously a million miles a second.
I go for him to say this right now to me means that this dude doesn't have a lot
to lose.
Like he's,
and also I think maybe,
you know what if he has a gun on him?
That was my thought.
And he's looking for,
he's looking at,
he's looking for an exchange,
right?
Yeah.
So I just absolutely just went,
I just shook my head like [inaudible] and then I turned back to the like of the
gas.
Yeah.
I think.
And then I just like a second pass and then I heard him and he'd ripped out of
their good.
At least he left you alone.
Oh,
I mean,
I was trying to diffuse,
but it wasn't like it's a dude was like,
where you go like,
Oh shit,
this guy,
this guy is going gonna fuck me up.
Yeah.
I looked at this guy like,
this dude has to be mentally ill.
Yeah.
Or,
or
sitting on a handgun right now in that car waiting,
just itching is waiting for me to say like,
what's up bitch?
Going to losers do.
Yeah.
I learned that lesson in public school too.
Don't,
don't look,
just don't look whatever shit is going down.
That's like the New York subway lesson.
Yeah.
You're like,
don't look out to do.
That's what I did.
Eyes down did.
I was down.
Don't even fight,
but I'll never forget those two.
Cause like I said,
the exact exchange was what's up dog.
And it's a brilliant,
he goes,
you acting like you know me,
homie.
I was like,
no sir.
I do not know you.
No Sir.
No.
That's so funny.
I kicked out.
Yeah,
he's probably cranked out.
Oh,
you know what's great is that we're teaching our son about creepers.
Yeah.
Hey,
that's a creeper.
Yeah.
Tell 'em that's what you've been telling us.
That guy's creepy.
Don't even look at that guy.
But you gotta teach your kids eyes down.
Don't even,
don't look at crazy.
I'll talk about it.
Don't address it.
No,
no vigilante,
you know,
don't taxi driver anything.
Just fucking eyes down,
dude.
You've got these crazy eyebrows are cat.
He's always like,
all right,
got your eyebrows.
Yeah,
I'm a native.
I'm from the Colorado.
Colorado's don't give a fuck
right now.
Let's go.
We got to though.
I love it.
Let's see.
This guy's hand going like this.
You see that?
Yeah.
This guy here and he's like,
he's mocking her as she does this.
Wow.
Let's go
real fucking fire.
I agree with her.
This is exactly how I feel.
Too crazy every time I'm on a plane so I,
if this bitch is on my plan,
I'd be like,
yes,
yes.
Thank you.
You know that it's,
and she's going too far with it,
but she does.
Oddly enough.
How a point she's got the right idea,
dude.
Good girl waving down my leg.
I have blood going down my legs off the plane.
I'm sorry.
I'm being nice.
Yeah,
she'd be a nice right now.
Well,
especially when you have your period,
you got to fucking roll do.
She broke this guy.
He's like,
they can't take it anymore.
I do.
I have to.
Do
y'all want to see what's going down my leg right now?
Matt knows I need to get to the
motherfucking.
I would just park the way for her.
What are you guys?
Move aside,
what is going on?
You know what I would do if I were that guy in front of her?
I be like,
Oh hey guys,
let this lady off.
Can everybody move aside and let her,
she's in pain.
Like why has nobody letting her off?
If she's that itchy to go like,
seriously,
she's in pain.
I just wouldn't want to hear it anymore.
Right.
That too.
I mean there's that too.
I would love for you to stop talking.
So let her go,
dude.
Definitely go hard.
The fucking waters.
I'm bleeding all over my vagina.
Straight blood all over this.
So get the fuck off the morning.
Get off the plane here that,
yeah,
dude,
I've been there too.
You've had blood running down your leg on a plane.
Yeah.
There had been times where I've had like,
not when I was pregnant and nauseous as fuck,
like get me off this or you're,
you have diarrhea.
You've had that right where you're like,
I got to shit.
We got to go bro.
Or you're in traffic and you're like,
Ooh,
okay.
You know that's the truth,
right horse.
No,
they never heard the fuck word.
We go on this quest am IME like you want to talk to me?
Want to talk some shit?
Ooh.
Shit.
You like that.
You know what I love is when people are like,
they're,
our children are children and you're,
your child's never heard the word fuck before or seen a crazy person right here.
You want to talk some shit?
Yeah.
Don't worry.
If you can explain things to your children,
you can explain that this woman is not well and needs happen.
Yeah.
There are children.
You have to stop living your lives.
My child is here.
That's right.
She's on her period
and turn around and get off the plane.
Yeah,
I get that.
She went back to,
can you do me a favor?
She went nice again.
She was like,
do me a favor and uh,
get your fucking ass up there.
Our children.
That's my favorite.
Goddamn that's children.
Never heard somebody that crazy.
Look,
look how mortified I am.
Yeah,
you're overheard.
Oh,
he's just so embarrassed.
He's so embarrassed.
He's like,
please make this shit happen.
So it,
oh,
smiles
ear to ear.
And you're just stoked.
Yeah.
Pupils are dilated.
So exciting.
Yeah.
This is my one.
I'm the one thing about New York City that I really like.
I'd moved there just for the subway.
Crazy because I feel like there's a lot more action in public in New York City
than in La.
100% but you're also with people all the time.
That's why you're,
you're,
you're in your car.
Yeah.
We don't get a lot of that.
No Fun crates.
Public crazy action.
No sucks.
Public crazy is the norm in New York and in San Francisco.
Downtown still has his bad it down out here though.
Last time I was in downtown La,
a guy in an alley,
but like taking a shit.
Is that together?
We were looking at potential loft.
We were considering moving there.
At one point he was standing,
standing and shitting.
I often think about how strong his thigh muscles must have been.
That's what you think about.
Yes.
Cause that was a prolonged squat.
He was half squatting.
He wasn't even like,
it's leaning in squatting.
It's hard.
But I mean,
he was,
he was so used to it that he just,
he just needs were barely bent.
I can't believe we have the same memory synergy.
That was real neat.
I do think about it and I saw the poo falling down.
That's the craziest part is that like we saw a man shitting and an alleyway
together together.
Together.
It was really,
really something in front of the children are his children here.
There's children then the anybody.
Does anybody care that there's children here?
We can't explain this to our child.
Um,
I think one of the best clips ever to grace your mom's house is that that
homeless guy,
he shifts in public homeless guy getting raped by gay goes.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's still even up there.
It's been so long.
But a special clip you a pad.
An interesting thing.
How would you finish this?
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
I thought we were going with our oh,
okay.
All these other responsibilities
for your family on board.
Not Necessary to drop the F bomb.
Okay,
great.
And we've already called integrity
security.
No,
she didn't have a bad,
she's going to bleed out.
She's got a bad by a bad bite.
Yeah.
She better get her fucking Tampon and look for that.
I'm bleeding all over my vagina.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
So you want to talk about dumps,
let's talk some shit.
You want to talk some shit and just talk it.
Oh,
next door.
Brown,
Todd Brown,
dark coming off.
So for those of you that don't know,
um,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm a brown guy,
brown master.
And for awhile I was like,
man,
I mean I even had a standup bit about having diarrhea all the time.
I got to the point where I said,
you know,
this is you.
You were like,
yeah,
this is pretty bad,
but I hear it all.
You had a bad bite.
Well,
and also,
um,
in is a joke of yours,
but the origin is in truth.
Yeah.
And that one time you had such a violent brown and this is in our home in silver
lake that I could hear it from the living room and you came out and I said,
do we have to go to the emergency room?
Yeah,
because it was so violent and that,
by the way,
I hear it echoing in my eye.
I still feel like I,
uh,
I feel like
I still farm or shit like that all the time.
Yeah,
all the time.
What do you mean you're still shitting like that?
No,
I'm saying I,
I,
I never felt like that really ended after that for years and years.
Years.
Yeah.
Well,
it started,
at least I acknowledged it.
I don't know if it started in silver lake.
How long have you been shedding like that?
I can't even,
I can't even tell you this a long time.
So it kept going and kept happening.
And then on this show I told you the
thank you a lot.
You seriously,
when he's in a bag,
I was serious about the fact that
I actually went to a gastroenterologist.
I just haven't heard the Camden.
Yeah.
Gosh,
that's good.
Okay.
So I went and I,
I saw this guy and then we scheduled a colonoscopy and they were going to check
out my poop Shit,
you know,
and I had it moved a bunch of times,
reschedule
risk.
We had,
we had moved houses
and
touring and touring.
So altogether I kept rescheduling it anyways.
At the same time the rescheduling was going on,
I was changing my diet and competing in this weight loss contest with Bart and
then,
you know,
I kind of forgot about the last time I scheduled or changed it.
So you know,
it ends and a or you know,
the contest ends and then I'm kind of in this new way of eating,
which is I basically live by an eat with a,
a Keto lifestyle,
which is high fat,
moderate protein,
no sugar,
no carbs.
I get my,
my net carbs come from vegetables.
Right?
Anyways,
that's basically how I eat.
Well,
ever since I've been eating like that,
I wasn't even really paying attention to it.
My browns changed to and then I kinda realized that I wasn't having these crazy
violent,
explosive shifts all the time.
And then this weekend,
you know,
I'm mostly a good boy,
but I decided like,
oh,
you know,
it's okay to have,
have fun every once in a while.
Right.
A little.
Yeah.
So we're out and we go,
hey,
you know,
what do you feel like I go,
I feel like having like a,
I want to,
I want to have like a sugary,
I haven't indulged in sugar in a minute,
so I want to go have like a sugary meal.
I want to have like a waffle or something.
So that's your go to binge?
Yeah.
I think my goto binge is wine.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You like wine,
cheese.
I like that a lot.
Yeah.
Well I haven't had,
you know,
like I said,
the French toast and forever,
so since the day you won the bed,
actually.
Yeah.
So I go,
you know,
it's,
it's fine to do it today and then you get back on the horse,
you know,
and you just do it for a meal.
You don't do it all day.
Yeah.
So,
and I also take the stuff that that helps me afterwards.
Uh,
has like direct vomit.
No,
I have it has key tones in it and everything.
I tell you to try that.
So anyways,
um,
we go the French toast is delightful.
It's,
you know,
it's great dude.
Within 10 minutes of eating it,
I can feel the bubbles in my gut and I have to rush home and run inside and I
have explosive,
crazy,
crazy doctor Ram
heritable.
And I mean it's,
and it reminded me that like,
oh,
that was more of like a standard shift for me eight months ago.
Right.
You would have [inaudible] constantly all the time.
Here's when you would have them.
I remember I would make a record mentally after snoozy because we would tend to
order the fried items.
Maybe like a tempura something.
Um,
sometimes rich.
Yeah.
Rich,
rich can do it to anyone.
Like creams,
like parents.
We'll do it too.
Do I mean something really rich,
something really greasy that can,
someone that can fuck with anyone's,
but yeah.
Yeah.
The cream sauces.
Fuck my ass up pretty bad.
But I thought that it was interesting that I haven't been indulging in sugar.
I have a sugar indulgence and boom goes the dynamite.
Right.
Bad.
Yeah.
I don't think that there's anything,
I don't think there's anything funnier to me personally.
Um,
as when I just over the years we've been together 12 years,
something like that and nothing makes me laugh harder
when we're driving home from any restaurant and the diarrhea hits you and you're
driving and you're like,
it does matter because I know that you're driving at the top of the speed limit.
And I can just,
I like,
I know where you are emotionally because I've been there too.
And I know it happens when the closer you get to the house.
Like it's like your asshole knows when you're pulling in the driveway and then
your butthole stumps to like spasm,
you know?
And that's even worse when you get the key in the door.
Cause you're like,
I'm going to shit my pants now.
It's like your butthole knows does.
No,
I mean it's a miracle that you can make it to the toilet.
Sometimes.
I had a belt on.
Remember I got to the bathroom on Saturday and I was like,
oh,
the fucking belt.
It was really bad.
But it makes me laugh so hard.
Every time I laugh.
Fucking so hard.
Damn.
That's funny,
Dude.
12 hours later,
everything's back to normal.
The next,
next few meals or normal,
normal shifts.
So you're back on the Kido.
That must be it.
It's got to be the carbs,
the sugar.
Maybe your,
what's that thing everyone has Ciliac I dunno.
Maybe.
What's that shit called,
man?
The fucking gluten shit.
I know what you're talking.
I've heard maybe have this irritant.
Isn't that what that is?
It's what?
It just feels like I took care of itself.
It's like,
I know you changed your diet.
No,
you're stopped eating that wheat.
The gluten cut it out of your diet and that maybe you had a gluten intolerance.
I don't know.
Who knows,
man.
But now I'm back to foreign like a man.
Oh Wow.
Here's a clip of you,
um,
from last night.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
There's,
yeah,
that's definitely a Trish moment.
Gosh,
she really gets down that ground.
Uh,
yeah.
You Nest?
He Fuck
No.
Does anyone say that they love making,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
I mean personally it's a little too theatrical for my tastes.
I would laugh really hard if you insist on being like,
yeah,
you fucking nasty bitch.
I was like,
Oh,
I love to do that.
Oh yeah,
yes.
Oh Wow.
That's not true.
True.
Bobby's a lot more abusive.
Here's Karen.
Honestly,
it wasn't a town and this is like this ghost promise all of the moment in the
scene.
It wasn't until somebody was actually there telling me,
you have to in you or you have three of you that like it.
Actually,
it kind of clicked and I'm like,
oh my God,
this is actually happening.
I'm proud of myself.
Did you see,
by the way,
this was amazing Harlem.
I thought that the president of the United States called us out by name.
He did.
Yeah.
How did I miss this?
I Dunno,
but somebody sent it to me and I,
my mouth dropped.
[inaudible] especially with everything going on right now to be directly
mentioned by name.
It was,
it's pretty remarkable.
I can't wait to see this.
Wow.
Well,
I'm going to start by thanking God and I want to take my whole team.
Yeah.
With duties.
I want to thank Tom and Christina,
why is your mom's house palm cash?
Show
of what?
Uh,
what?
Yeah,
mom's house.
What?
He got it pretty close.
And Christina,
I'll feel mom's house.
Palm cash show Comcast.
You know what a podcast is?
Um,
no.
Yeah.
You don't know.
He does.
Wow.
I can't believe we got to shut out from low trim 90.
I know.
That's amazing.
I feel like we're so,
we really made it will follow me all over the streets.
I want to thank BB and w booty love out of big Buddhist Day.
Lo.
I want to thank five 18 street all over the streets.
You see,
he is um,
uh wow.
I feel like we're in such good company with these little booties and he's
signing revised travel ban.
Um,
and,
and a new,
uh,
I guess there's,
there's a new policy about deportations as well.
Have you seen this?
This is a new trend,
man.
Today was Sandy's Zegna oh,
car pull up a be deployed in a motherfucking bad coke.
We did pay him a,
we will be deported.
We don't give a damn what got damn country.
You go to a way your ass gone be in.
We don't give a fuck looking at people stand up the land in front of you when
they paying below the A's and the dro stuck in a booty.
Yeah,
that's a good,
that's a good law.
Well I think we should suggest this to the pres.
He's right.
I mean yeah.
Suggests it looks like it's already about to become law
to be stand up in front of you.
And he drove down to
truth.
That hair is amazing.
It's a really good,
a weird guy.
I don't know where he got it.
Yeah,
it looks good.
No longer have to look at it cause we use now to put an age and like I told you
a mirror,
I got your bed.
I love the president.
The president to his outfits gotten better from 90s and he really seems to be
getting into character.
This is great.
My favorite thing is that,
you know,
now him and us together,
we run into industry now,
you know,
we're running this industry.
How great would it be if this guy really did give like all the talks,
all the speeches,
take over the Twitter at Cambia approval rating would be much higher,
much.
I would love this guy to be president.
Actually,
I'm going to keep the motherfuckers out.
That's the new,
uh,
that's the new travel ban.
Anybody from any of those countries,
we don't keep them motherfuckers out and keep them out.
Man.
Running the industry now.
I love it.
He's really the greatest [inaudible] is growing on me now.
I mean,
now that we got to shout out and everything,
it's pretty crazy.
Maybe it's my vanity,
but he appealed to it and I like it.
Do you remember the guy that taught us Oi Oi Mandarin course?
Yeah.
He's got another one out.
What's up fam?
Blood blood oil.
Mandan.
Yes.
You're like a lush today.
I'm off to ask or to get some Zider.
I've arrived in bristle trust drive.
Hello Ron.
This is Philly.
Today I'm going to talk about Bristol dialect.
Was
Bristol stool chart words?
Yeah.
Bristo Bristol.
It's the same Bristol,
by the way.
Right?
Is the Bristol stool chart came from?
Wow.
Is that,
wow.
I did not put that together.
How do you think Bristol's proud of that?
That they 100% of course.
Is there a museum commemorating the chart?
Possibly.
Possibly,
yeah.
All right,
let's hear it.
You need to remember that Bristol is called Bristol by local people because of
the action
appraisal.
Brazil,
Brazil.
The best one is a phrase and it's our big,
it looks like a different language,
right?
It's from the phrase how beat and it means how long.
Oh,
it's useful that they can person in old English in Bristol.
Phil uses it.
Oh,
you mean in Bristol?
Braise our best.
So next one is
in Bristolian mean very old people in Bristol Sake or at lush,
which means very good.
Good,
lush.
Good God,
Norbert.
Oh,
me mate.
I guess get good.
Sounds like good.
Is that why good?
It's good.
Gosh,
this is really specific.
Jeez man.
Damn.
My whole thing is do you think the people,
the most hilarious thing would be people watching this video in what?
Korean,
he's Korean are traveling there and being like,
or gut lush like to go get rush.
No.
Lush,
nope,
you're doing it wrong.
Let's take a look at an example sentence.
Hey,
how are you?
You look very good today.
I'll bet you'll like her lunch today.
So damn.
But,
but nothing was more absurd than a foreigner trying slang,
you know,
cause he's keys working at a double deficit like will and the people he's
teaching art are definitely,
should not be trying to,
cause if you're a traveling they're negative and then they're going to be like,
oh you look great girl.
Lush today we're going to look like a fucking asshole.
Yeah.
It's a,
I mean it's,
it's entertaining but our cookie from old English and it usually means look at
him.
Okay.
It's from the word Hawk.
Come on.
Listen.
In old English
I can't,
they just talk normal walk at e.
Okay.
Is that really what's happening now?
I feel like,
I feel like it's learning slang from the Internet.
Like,
you know when you're like fleek and you're like,
yeah,
but nobody's really saying that shit.
I don't know.
I mean,
or whatever.
I feel like this is the answer net equivalent of what's cool cause we,
whenever we air this guy,
we usually get emails like nobody really says,
man,
dumb or that's so nineties or that's not what really is happening.
Stop stops.
You might think,
oh,
fishing when you hear this related to fishing in Bristolian means playing souls.
It's a fucking one.
Oh for fuck off.
Fuck.
Do you,
um,
do you think his sweatshirt looks like he's on a new season of Star Trek?
You told me.
Oh my God,
I tried on a zip up jacket,
you know,
like a casual zip,
zip her upper and you're like,
you're on the new season of star was look like seven of nine or whatever.
Fucking stupid character named seven of nine.
Is that what her name is?
I don't know.
Is that really a name?
Yeah.
Really?
A guy from reading rainbow and he had on a banana comb on his,
over his eyes and that was his like thing.
And you're like,
fuck a banana comb on that guy's eyes.
Yeah,
that's what he always wore his jam.
That's not even a thing.
Right.
Here we go again.
Here we go with the jam here.
When we found pictures of Garth Brooks with his first wife
Julie Moon.
And
this will be my wicked witch.
Laughter video.
Hi Aaron.
I hold on.
I mean you can't just why?
What happened?
I feel like you needed to set me up a little.
I don't know what it is.
Why are you not preparing?
I know it was Julie Moon.
Now.
Dammit.
Hold on.
Let me get comfortable.
I got to like sit back a little and fucking ease into something crazy like this.
Yeah,
you didn't tell me we are going full crazy.
Yeah.
I used to be famous for doing this laugh in college.
Can you'll remember?
Oh Shit.
Okay.
And this is my maleficent head dress wearing,
which I like to put it on Halloween and scare the crap out of little kids.
What is there going?
What's going on?
There is a pronoun.
Yup.
And this is what having a stressful day does to Julie Moon.
Oh,
and I'm naked,
but this is all you're seeing up here.
Oh,
okay.
so it is okay.
Just be like,
Hey,
hi.
How are you?
What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?
Cause there's a little,
there's a little confusion.
I'm confused,
but it's not a is Julie.
No.
Now we know because I'm naked.
But this is all you're seeing Julie.
Now you know it's a woman.
Yeah.
But there was a little confusion.
I was,
if you're listening only you,
you can't tell you.
It's definitely sounds like a woman,
but if you're,
you're viewing you,
you know what I mean?
What's Your Pronoun?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No.
Okay.
Get ready.
That's a good character.
That's really good.
But yeah,
what's up with the dental update?
You know,
uh,
I gotta tell you,
you got to get those teeth fixed,
man.
That's the thing about the great British baking show.
I meant to right now.
And yeah,
I watched one with you last night.
Finally.
I got you on board.
Now it almost feels like you indulge in sweets after you watch that show.
Since we don't eat carbs anymore,
I feel like at least I can watch people baking them a soap,
but their teeth are so fucking gnarly.
Julie's our bad.
Julie's are bad too,
but yeah,
I support you.
But I support a dental visit.
And just for your viewing pleasure,
I'm showing in a bonus.
Generally evil doing maniacal type laugh.
Oof.
I liked the first lap was good for his laugh was better the second,
the second lap when,
no,
no.
I'm thinking from an animation casting standpoint,
right.
That's not a strong voice.
No,
the first one was good though.
Yeah.
Someone took hammers to her.
Deserves teeth.
Yeah.
It doesn't like it then.
Now the thing is you can get those invisaligns now and I think there are a
fraction of the cost of what braces were.
Yeah.
So now there's really little excuse people and why not just get the perfect
smile.
Yeah.
Then I mean,
you can,
uh,
you can get him,
we're a date,
but you,
you can eat
Jannie.
You can't smile too hard.
You can't eat,
you can't drink.
Go to a thousand ranch dotcom and buy some tickets to see those big mushy
purples.
Yeah.
Um,
big shows,
big shows coming up for,
for Zim.
And I'm going to be in Bethlehem,
PA this Thursday.
Jesus was born where Jesus was born at the sands casino.
There are still some tickets left,
uh,
come out.
If you didn't make it to the Philly show or the Atlantic city show,
make the trip.
Come see me at the sands casino.
Um,
what else?
I am going to be at Foxwoods casino in a Mesh and Tuck it on Friday.
It's sold out three shows at the Wilbur in Boston.
Those are all gone.
But uh,
the following week,
Green Bay,
Wisconsin,
then two shows in debt,
Trois Royal Oak actually.
And then four shows in Chicago at the Vic.
There's only tickets available to the fourth show,
which is on Sunday,
Sunday on a Sunday.
All eight shows at the DC Improv are sold out.
And then,
um,
I have added shows in tits,
Pennsylvania,
in Burlington,
Vermont,
in Fallis,
Texas on four 20 and a few more.
Portland.
I added a show in May because of the April shows being sold out and I've added a
show in,
in meat rattle,
Seattle,
Washington.
I'm very excited about all of them.
They're all at Thomson [inaudible] dot com on the tour page.
Thank you guys for supporting me.
And coming to these shows have been in this tour has been an incredible amount
of fun.
I also have a bunch of dates that are to be announced and as soon as,
uh,
as everything is signed and dotted,
I'll announce all of those.
Oh yeah.
Including some intern
national jeans,
international gene.
Yeah.
It's exciting.
Yeah,
it's exciting.
Very exciting.
Oh,
Houston Houston's also on sale.
It's in April.
So come on out.
You sit him probably five shows.
All Right,
Jean,
April 13th and 15th,
I met the bread Improv,
uh,
April 28th or 29th,
Sacramento at the punchline.
May 4th through fifth,
Phoenix at standup live.
May 19th or 20th two Dork titties at Gotham comedy club.
June one through three Denver at Denver,
Denver.
Come on,
your works.
The downtown Best Club in America.
I'm so excite.
Best Club in America.
And then,
um,
my smurf day weekend,
June 16th and 17th,
man friend disco at the punchline comedy club.
Come see me do stand up please.
Yeah.
Also check out.
That's deep bro.
It was a
brow.
Uh,
if you're interested in that cause that's the podcast.com shopping.
If you're shopping on Amazon,
use our banner.
Please go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom of the homepage.
Your shopping as you normally would just kicks back some change.
And now we've added the UK as well.
So if you're there and in Canada,
do your shopping name,
shop there.
Yay.
Hooking.
Who's really,
who knows or hoser hoes or I don't know if we covered,
um,
we didn't talk about God pipe classic,
right?
I mean we,
I know we mentioned it last week,
but I didn't feel like we really got into it.
And W I mean,
I don't know,
maybe we did,
but it's enough.
It's,
it's big enough to emphasize that it might be that you just have to dehydrate
yourself.
No,
we did talk about,
I know we talked about it,
but I don't know.
It was just such a revelation that I did we talk about our weekend or night off?
It didn't.
No,
we haven't even done.
We did it and we got to encourage you to do it.
Especially if you're a new parents,
but as long,
especially if you,
you know,
if you have kids,
not that new new shit.
What'd you got?
Damn kids.
What's your kids a year old and you can lock him in a crate.
Leave a bottle,
leave him a diaper change.
Easy peasy.
Go look.
Take this one off.
Queen.
Put this.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Good a night away.
So good.
We slept and slept til eight.
Awesome.
That was amazing.
I fell asleep.
I fell asleep at 10 and woke up at eight.
That's the longest I've slept in,
I would say easily two years.
And I mean that like that,
you know,
especially cause you can't really relax with the kid in the house.
You got to get out of the house.
You got to go to a hotel or go or someone take baby.
Because if I hear him even like running around,
it's,
you're still in.
I'm still in mom though.
Of course you can't even nap when you hear a kid like making noise.
Really?
No,
it was great.
Yeah.
So anyways,
we made a reservation again next month,
once a month we're going to spend the night away and we're going to just rest
and it's drank during the day.
It was fucking awesome.
I never do that anymore.
I mean,
by that I mean like I had to hold glasses of wine before sundown and then one,
uh,
with dinner and I was like,
I'm ripped.
I'm hammered.
It was really,
really fun,
man.
God Damn.
We were only,
you know,
20 minutes away.
That's the best part is that it's really close to where we live.
And then we had Sushi for dinner and the best part is that we ordered a fuck
load of Sushi and our waiter didn't,
judge,
didn't judge it all kept suggesting things,
give it,
gave us things that weren't on the menu,
created things for us.
And at the very end goes,
thanks chains.
Yeah,
we're like,
what?
What?
This whole time.
He's like,
yeah,
mommy,
this is a fucking,
first of all,
we're always pleased to meet a mommy in any corner of the world,
but your Sushi server,
come on.
That's perfect for us.
It's symbiotic.
Yeah,
it was,
it,
it totally changed the whole,
you know,
well,
just finally to not be judged for the amount of food that we've been ordering at
Sushi cause we've been ordering a lot.
It was real cool.
Yeah.
And he gave us dessert and everything.
Oh,
so good craze craze jeans.
Um,
having a lot of laughs too.
The missile knows where it is at all times.
It knows this because it knows where it isn't,
where it is from,
where it isn't or where it isn't from where it is,
whichever is greater,
it obtains a difference or deviation.
Yeah.
Wow.
That was boring.
What do you think?
That didn't even make sense?
Yeah.
The guidance subsystem uses deviations to generate corrective command to drive
the missile from a position where it is to a position where it isn't.
And arriving at a position where it wasn't,
it now is
this reminds me,
right.
The voice.
That voice over guy reminds me so much of school.
Right.
That's a school.
It's a school video,
voice to Boring driveways and then do you,
would you ever look back and go,
was any of that worth it?
Any of those things?
I learned cause somewhere,
but don't you feel like someone,
you're like,
I didn't need to learn any of that shit.
There's a lot that,
it's not practical knowledge,
but I will say it.
It makes your brain,
it's like brain gymnastics so that you can retain and understand things.
It's just gymnastics and I guess so,
but you don't remember any of that shit.
I like this.
They would teach you something like this and you're like,
this fucking sucks now.
I don't know why they have to phrase it that way from where it is to where it
isn't to where it was to where it works.
Huh?
Sequentially.
The position where it is is now the position that it wasn't,
I didn't know shit.
The position that it was is now the position that it isn't.
This is like
this.
It makes them no sense.
That's the missile
in the event that the position that it is in is not the position that it wasn't.
The system has acquired a variation.
The variation being the difference between where the missile is and we're at
wasn't it?
Variation is,
I feel like this is,
um,
that's how an engineer's brain work for something.
Yeah.
This is why smart people were then the muscles and they go,
this is exciting.
So,
and this is fun.
Yeah.
But this is why dumb dumbs like us don't have our finger on the button of these
things and smart people do.
This is more our speed right here.
Imagine if some Dukie going,
welcome free.
Yes.
Yeah.
Lit a torch to loosen this pipe.
You know,
you'll be out.
Right.
And the guide doesn't heat it up.
Not talking about it.
Stop talking about it.
It's a chain
as the,
that sacco,
right?
Yeah.
There's some pipe in the base.
Yep.
So see,
it's leaking already.
Yeah.
You're calm.
Maybe stand back.
Dude.
There's no time to throw up right now.
He's not going to tell a lie.
He doesn't,
he doesn't work through it.
Don't lie to me.
He's just grossed out.
Work through it.
You've got this right.
Hey,
dry.
Even close.
Why are you showing me a fucking Barf club dues?
Is that a Barf clip?
His friends just laughing at how gross Goudy is.
Wow.
That's an evil character,
by the way.
That's a malesan capital and I go,
why are you showing me the fucking bomb?
And it doesn't vomit.
He's bending over like he's,
well,
he's grossed out.
That's the whole point.
Yeah.
Don't have vomit.
No promise.
Next a clip.
Oh Huh.
Huh.
Hmm.
I feel like he does what?
That guy.
Oh,
you feel like him?
Yeah.
Great.
What do you think's in that pipe dude?
His Fred.
He's just fucking with him.
It's the best.
Where do you think,
can you imagine about,
isn't it funny that that's his line of work?
Sewage?
Well,
I mean the guy's so grossed out by a lot like his line of work.
It not like this is the first pipe.
He's done that too.
Is this his line of work or it will look,
he's a novice.
He knows what he's doing,
I guess.
I mean,
he,
he took the thing off.
He's,
he's cleaning.
Get out now.
Show floor.
Juki sitting on the floor.
Oh,
shut the fuck.
I mean,
wouldn't you where I'm at.
Okay.
I'm out.
I'm fucking tapped out of his club,
bro.
Why?
What is wrong with you?
You're ruining the show right now.
You're ruining the show.
You know,
I hate,
I haven't seen this though,
right?
No,
I haven't.
I have no blue.
Bam prepared it and you know,
I'll do it.
Yeah.
Okay,
awesome.
I'll do it.
This dude chuck is,
Oh,
I'm going to get a Goddamn,
wait,
no,
no.
It's over.
It's not over.
Liar
over God.
Here's a worst.
This is for you.
Just to go back to this,
oh,
hello and welcome to another edition of her Reba Robin Academy.
This installment will discuss Raman spectroscopy and specifically micro Raman
spectroscopy.
Jesus.
Yes,
we buy it to molecular electronic material.
You'd rather watch this then the Duke you guys all day.
Of course,
air day,
Jesus,
defects of orientation and crystallinity.
There's videos like Reba Romine Academy,
one in the world.
Is this,
this is just a short cover,
these topics,
uh,
first,
an introduction or reintroduction,
I'm sure to many of you,
the field effect transistor,
you know,
uh,
my dad called me this week and there's amaze me lab.
He read me jokes.
Oh No.
Oh yeah.
I got to get them to record it.
No,
he called me like I was driving and he was laughing so hard and I was like,
where are you?
How are you memorizing these?
Cause like not guy emailed me Matt Green Gay and he was getting them wrong as he
read them.
I go,
that's not how that joke out.
He's like,
oh well,
yeah,
yeah.
Like stumbling over it.
He's like more or less.
That's the job.
More or less.
Yeah.
Isn't that funny?
You got to get it right though.
For it to be funny.
Jokes are all about precision.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
so fun.
I do what I was thinking,
how stupid I am.
How you were saying.
Yeah.
Do you remember any of this shit from school?
Like if our sun were to ask me,
hey,
why does it rain?
I'll be like,
I don't fucking know.
Like I don't even know why.
Right.
I'm like,
no,
I really don't.
I'm not sure how to do long form division.
I can't fucking do that shit.
I'd be like,
I remember you think you got to carry something.
Remainders is a remainder to,
okay.
You want to see a funny video?
So this in class tomorrow,
this uh,
why is the sky blue?
Uh,
some about the ocean.
I don't fucking know this cause the light Google this guy cause light hits this
guy and it turns blue.
Yeah.
So I would say what causes rainbows,
son?
The gaze piss the air and it makes it blue.
The gays,
the gays,
the sky,
and they love blue.
So that's why,
uh,
the blessing in the sky,
he's a dad.
Boner,
uh,
getting excited.
Oh yeah.
A chicken in the pool.
There you go.
There's an excited dad that dads can't curse to get,
Dad's got a say.
Fricking fricking cool.
Fricking clue.
Good.
Cool.
Your Dad doesn't talk like that.
Come on now.
My Dad's a real man.
Yeah,
he doesn't say frigging at all.
There's no such,
I don't think my dad knows the word frickin.
Yeah.
He'd say like,
why the fuck do you say fricking?
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
You know,
I kind of am of that school.
I don't know.
We'll see how my kid turns out,
but yeah,
I'm cares.
Let him say fuck word with somebody right here.
Um,
hey mommy's,
I'm writing to let you know that Rick would,
the xannies is almost 100%.
I can't put this person is better than we are.
The same guy who texted you a few a few months ago,
sticks on deck.
Oh Shit.
In my opinion,
he should have gone Lincoln.
Ah,
as a favorite of mommy.
And you could text Rick and let him know.
I keep,
I need 10 keeping them high and tight from Virginia.
Alex,
I didn't even put that shit to.
Yeah,
thanks Bro.
That's so I didn't even realize sticks animal.
What were the stakes again?
Xanax.
Ah,
shit man.
Linkedin is helpful.
So there you go,
Alex.
Thank you very much.
Thank you,
Dan.
Hey mommies.
I have,
uh,
I don't have anyone that I feel like an ass about this in my personal life.
And you always seem to have rock solid advice on things like this.
I have issues with my ass.
It itches sometimes,
which I think is kind of normal,
but I also have issues making Brown.
Oh,
the cleaning up part more specifically,
I noticed when a coworker comes in to make chocolate next to me,
they wipe way less than I do.
I could just be,
it could just be that they don't require the cleanliness that I do.
Or it could be the amount of hair I have on my asshole.
Hmm.
I need a good four or five pieces of toilet paper and I average a good three
wipes per piece.
Others sound like they wipe two or three times total.
It seems like I work way harder than them to not,
not to mention smashing hair into my asshole.
It's like rubbing it with a what?
A pad causing it to bleed.
Sometimes wood shaving my ass be a recommendation you would recommend at this.
Well you would make at this point.
Thanks.
Genes love the podcast.
Joel.
Joel,
interesting question and I would do is really your leg.
Oh it is 100% in my lane.
I drive.
I've been down this path many times.
There's two things I can tell you.
First of all,
the answer is yes.
I think,
um,
I know I've done it before.
Sometimes you hear me talking about it like I got to make that appointment
again.
I got to get that done again.
It absolutely changes your cleanup game,
your cleanup game.
When you have a hairy asshole.
It's not fun.
It's time consuming.
It's a,
it's honestly,
it's stressful and losing all that hair.
I mean you'll,
you would be amazed.
I would consider,
I wouldn't,
I would actually wax it.
And here's why.
It sounds scarier than it is.
Um,
you think is going to be like this unbearable pain.
It's not,
it just feels like,
like just,
yeah,
you just feel a little tug.
It's not any more.
It's not someone's stabbing your asshole.
The hairs come out like anywhere else.
It feels fine.
I would recommend doing it.
The other part of it though.
I think the drawback,
some people will tell you you're going to maybe sweat more or cause there's
nothing there to collect it.
No,
I think it's definitely a a reasonable thing.
But as we mentioned earlier in this podcast,
maybe a diet change.
That's what
I was going to suggest.
What's coming out of your asshole.
Yeah,
let's start with the root cause here because don't you feel like waxing his bud
hair is,
it's,
it's an effect.
Not the cause.
Like let's get to the root.
Well,
but it's still either way it's going to change other way it's going to change.
It is it.
And also I recommend as somebody who went shit to shower for a years because I
have a clean ass hole.
I have a hairless asshole more or less and my wipes were disastrous for a long
time and I would just go,
shit,
the showers we mentioned maybe consider investing in a toto washlet for your
home,
but then you get to work and it's like,
well why are you shitting?
I think you should move your shitting schedule.
Shit in the morning,
drink your coffee and then you're not shooting at work.
Can you?
Can you move around?
You're dumping schedule's a little
Nah,
I mean it's a possibility.
I would say that.
I think just for a life experience.
Try Waxing your ass ones if you're a hairy guy.
Yeah,
and I would say since it's a work toilet and who gives a fuck?
If you clog it,
bring some wipes.
You can bring wipes you,
I think you can do an easy way.
Bring a bottle of water with you into the bathroom.
Topdog and what are you bringing about spit in the toilet paper.
He can bring water into the bottle of water with a cap on it.
Why not?
That's disgusting.
No,
it's not for a little bit of that on there and you just,
you lose.
I do it all the time when I'm traveling.
Of course.
What are you talking about?
Like in an airport?
You're shitting in a stall.
I don't even know.
What are you talking about?
I feel like you're a stranger.
I do spit on the paper.
If I'm in there and I don't have water,
but if I have water I'll pour it on the paper and then wipe my ass with that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's also discuss the inferior quality of office.
Toilet paper.
Horrible.
Don't,
don't judge.
First of all,
all never judge your cleanup amount with your neighbors cleaning.
I agree with that.
We got to stay in your own cleanup lane it sounds like.
Yeah.
The person next to you is doing less but maybe they're lazy,
you don't know and inferior.
They're just trying to paper different.
Come in their balls and maybe you don't.
Now your cleanup is going to be different at the office because of the inferior
quality of toilet paper.
Keep that in mind.
Try not to judge yourself.
Try not to be so hard on yourself with how much toilet paper you're using.
Cause you got to use double the squares.
If it's a single ply.
Everybody knows this.
Yeah.
You got to use a lot of toilet paper in the office and in an airport you go
through half a brought his own role.
Uh,
I mean the thing is you got to manage that role,
you know,
but I would,
I would definitely bring water or wet wipes into wet wipes,
wet wipes.
I might even suggest,
uh,
you know,
going to rite aid and getting a little thing of personal kleenex.
Yeah.
Cause that's
[inaudible] then office toilet paper.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I like your idea of,
of bringing a water.
It's just kind of,
I feel conspicuous.
Will people notice what he's doing?
I don't think they'll,
I don't think they pay attention.
They won't know.
No,
he just drank it.
You walk around your water and then he'd go in there,
take it in the can.
No,
somebody emailed this.
Thank you for that very thought provoking question.
I could spend all day talking about that question.
I am an insurance adjuster for property casualty and liability claims.
Unfortunately,
boring video.
No,
no.
Unfortunately I could not record this for legal reasons,
but that was in a house yesterday and it was a good two hour drive to get to the
location on the way down.
I was listening to them cast and almost out of reflex.
The misses of the house offered me a water and I thanked her s saying,
thanks jeans.
And she said,
third.
She said,
sure thing mommy,
a look was exchange and we started laughing.
Needless to say,
the inspection took longer than expected as we proceeded to use and most of the
cash wages while discussing her claim.
If my son wins his regional wrestling tournament this weekend,
I will send the video because it is bound to be a huge dad boner on my part.
Stay classy and Tom is the water and personality camp.
Love your genes.
Rob,
will rob.
Good luck to your son.
I hope you have a huge dead boner and lose your mind if he wins.
By the way,
we got sent in of course more.
Do you want to see some,
hey mommy's thanks.
Jeans or
Horace.
I love these.
These are my favorite.
First of all,
there's also been some chatter out there on the interwebs that I might be the
burp champion.
Who the fuck is saying that?
You know,
just people from last week's Promo on Instagram.
A lot of let's just a lot of activity,
people insinuating that I might be the burp champ,
just glass and they're just thinking about it.
I don't think that,
I don't know.
I'm not encouraging it.
Yeah.
I'm not saying I'm the
champ.
Uh Huh.
Okay.
Whatever you guys,
you know,
I'll leave it up to the audience.
You guys are the big deciders.
Let's see what we got here.
I haven't seen any of these.
Oh,
I'm so excited to take them.
The burp champ.
But if you look at the video or the playback of this podcast,
I've definitely,
you cheated with your liquid.
I cheat.
Can I have some [inaudible] the kwan please.
Oh,
we're going to get paid today.
Can we get a brown tie and get a chocolate milk
and then go don't pike class.
I can probably get to Hash browns
and then the king man Prov by.
Can I get a number?
10 is wow.
Breakfast.
Yeah,
no problem.
What's the drive of that?
Uh,
I'll do coffee.
Coffee of Improv.
And would you like milder hot tub?
A.
Okay.
I get a hot sauce,
then the problem will they be agreed?
That's it.
Alright,
awesome.
Thanks for of Improv is a
great,
great reference.
Those of you that don't know that is a Seagal reference.
He um,
in an interview once said that he was the king of Improv.
If I,
if I say is,
if you don't mind me,
my saying,
so I believe it was something like that crazy person is totally insane thing to
say,
but um,
definitely on brand for him.
Uh,
that was really good.
Thank you very much for that job.
Logan.
Good jeans.
Really good jeans.
Um,
Gosh.
Let's see.
Uh,
there's another one here.
Yeah.
Who Do you want to say?
A special area?
Give me a second.
I'm just glassing
thank you.
How do you spell fart?
Wow.
Nice job.
Shame on me.
I'm ready.
Yeah.
Can I just get a strawberry message where you are a large group?
Um,
no,
that'd be it.
I think James,
well,
I love getting the next generation in a show,
you know,
here's the,
uh,
few jobs,
but that was fantastic,
Larry.
And you're adorable.
When I am the king of in province for free.
If you'll forgive my
Paul Stop Jarrett.
Uh Wow.
Honestly,
I think I would,
uh,
like some that didn't greasy doesn't smell or burns.
Uh,
just give me one second.
I'm just glassing for a bit and I'll be able to let you know.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Okay.
So I do want the for,
for,
where is he?
With a double stack
and a sprite to drink.
Um,
let's see what else Sharkey should know.
So I'm sorry about that.
Um,
so got,
oh yeah.
And then a number six.
Um,
I'll go full Burton.
Make it large with a Dr Pepper and that should do it.
Outrageous.
Alrighty.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
That's really good.
Wow.
Thank you.
That's plank.
He's amazed.
Very sheer.
There's amaze.
Yeah.
Really good stuff.
Oh my God.
They're doing jeans off the police swapping similar license registration
insurance please.
I'll just glassing the avenue.
Come down to a 49,
25.
I got a nice car,
but can be doing the slick stuff.
Needs stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
You feel me?
No
money on the updated insurance card.
No Way.
Same policy.
We one second.
All right.
No Way.
This has to be a voiceover over.
Okay.
All right.
James,
I'm going to give you a warning,
right?
Just do me first water and stay hydrated right in water champ.
That's hilarious.
I mean,
I guess it could,
but it's,
I dunno.
A Blue Band told me this had come in as a dash cam recording where the guy did a
full pull over with with jeans language.
I had no idea.
We had such fans and law enforcement.
I had no clue.
Okay.
They do and jeans off our license registration.
Sure.
I think it's real gene.
Yeah.
Oh,
just glass on the avenue.
Come down to a 40 and 25
I got a nice car.
We can be doing this.
Slick stuff needs stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
You feel me?
It sounds like the sound of 10 years real.
That's true.
It does sound
malaria's St policy.
Holy Shit.
One second.
All right.
That is unreal,
man.
All right.
Right.
Just do me first floor and say hydrogen.
We the water champ.
That's a whole fucking,
that's amazing.
We just upped the,
the,
the high mommy thinks jeans game.
Now you understand that this,
this tape opens up the category.
Yeah.
I mean you can incorporate,
hi mommy thinks jeans.
Basically.
Jeans speak basically gene speak is what we invented.
Yeah.
You can incorporate gene speak in all your professional lives as unreal.
Unreal.
I mean we,
the,
we had a the Improv right?
And she's answering the phones.
Uh,
yeah.
we had the liquor store clerk doing hi mommy.
Thanks jeans.
So now we're in law enforcement.
We have infiltrated all corners of the world.
It's amazing.
Do you know how to make a double pipe class?
Is that a bar two full turns with your body bend over right here?
No,
it's a uh,
it's a shot.
Uh,
Cincinnati far bourbon,
a little bit of Bourbon,
a core and a shout out.
Patrion Holy Shit.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
They're very rare.
Gossip.
Don't sound familiar at all.
Was playing classic.
Yeah.
I think Hillary's the drink thing popped up.
Yeah,
it does.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh
yeah.
I thought in Rio.
I think king ass ripper drank them too.
Oh,
king ass rapper.
he's,
he's big thing.
Uh,
he,
he's the king of farts.
Cmi.
Yeah.
You should look him up on Youtube.
He's a,
he's so amazing.
Pressure builds up the part time.
Oh my God.
It's,
it's kind of damage.
Yeah,
he's right.
I mean this is,
this is amaze.
Like we've started what was started like as a drive Thru joke as now a face to
face bartender joke.
It's crazy.
It's now law enforcement pulling people over in cars.
It's bananas.
It's just,
it's so far as it not going to go.
It's so fun.
Congress
tension genes.
We're voting on this bill.
This is so funny.
God.
Oh real goodness.
Yeah.
Isn't Spanish?
Hold on Mommy.
Uh,
Dameon and momentum is dark glass.
Sandow Yolk ghetto.
Those Barbecue Burritos.
No Garden.
They boil.
Oh,
you're fine.
Actually,
I met this goal,
Betsy CN Columbo,
but I'll sort of meant they own or do I go to the,
come over?
No,
it's 20
Cornog walk going on about their day.
Oh,
very impressed.
So please take a,
the oil can be on the hour.
He told her
that was my last,
I know
I did school bay.
Knowing bought
oil can be on the hour.
Mark Champ.
Deanna says Violetta asthma.
Havas
purple machines.
Yeah,
I this school bay knowing bought it that
Ghetto Montenegro.
K as the outdoor.
We operate though.
I want to make sure you're high and tight.
See us dot.
Although Grazia Dunes.
Amazing.
Wow.
All Spanish order for Dan to finish jeans now.
Thanks man.
Believable.
That's okay.
Mommy,
can I get a case?
Surrito oh,
it sounds good.
Beef chicken or steak.
Beef.
Um,
does that come with any pot pie?
Any pup play
pup play?
No,
it's not.
It's okay.
All right.
Thank you mommy.
That's how he yeah,
he's got her to calm down though.
It's something says,
oh my God was a,
that was Maria and Jean.
Good job.
Marie and Jean.
Good Job Jane.
Oh,
real good.
Talk about,
seems to be high on their menus today.
Yeah.
Taco bell and finally,
um,
some,
uh,
your nose.
Oh yes.
For a week here.
Feel like you didn't get a rest your minds a little bit.
I mean,
you can kind of,
you know,
what else do we add?
And you know,
obviously you get to get all your clothes washed and uh,
you know,
get comfortable a little bit and,
just get back to the basics and you know,
what's,
uh,
know what's made us,
you know,
good so far.
We've got a 2001.
She was really suburban.
Well,
I mean,
I think every game you just got to put behind you and move on to the,
you know,
when the next one,
we got a,
you know,
a nice little home stand here.
Um,
you know,
we just got to focus on,
uh,
you know,
his first one and you know,
Jesus and just get back to basics and,
you know,
continue to find the points that we need.
Yeah.
How many you knows,
is this guy got to many,
you know,
I feel like,
um,
you know,
we played this guy before.
Yeah.
His name is Dustin and I think we couldn't say his last name before and I still
can't say it is by food.
Foodlion he's a hockey player.
Is a maple leaf.
Just got to find a way that,
you know,
it makes every guy in here,
what do they call it?
Of course,
on the same way
Maybelline,
Paul,
you know,
looks a lot.
No,
I make this team.
He's this the best we can be.
You know,
with the guys,
with a lot of you guys made different,
you know,
you know.
Yeah.
It's just,
you know,
here's the,
super cut.
You're on and you know,
you know,
they know.
You know,
and you know,
just,
you know,
once,
you know by thank,
you know,
scale,
I don't,
you know,
you,
hey,
no,
we know.
We,
we noticed,
you know,
uh,
no,
you know,
I don't know.
He's not,
he's a,
he's a Winnipeg jet is not a maple.
Oh yeah.
That was the jet.
Oh.
But he's wearing their hat.
No,
no,
that's a jet ski as a jet within that.
Oh
know,
you know,
God,
he really,
you know,
really doing a lot of,
no,
you know,
I mean,
he's almost at top dogs level,
you know,
top dog,
you know.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
you know,
I couldn't believe I knew that my dad was bad,
but,
um,
he facetimed us on the toilet the other day.
Yeah.
Yesterday we were having breakfast with little jeans.
And your dad was facetiming on the toilet.
Yeah.
I didn't want to look at them.
I pretended like I couldn't see him,
but you know,
you could,
you know,
you know.
Yeah.
It was,
um,
it was way more,
uh,
then I wanted to see at that time of my dad.
You've seen him shit a lot though.
Yeah.
I didn't want to,
I didn't want him to,
to,
to shit in front of me.
No,
he was nice enough to,
uh,
he was nice enough to hang up to wipe though.
I don't know if you remember that.
I do remember when we were talking to your mom on their anniversary last week.
Yeah.
She was looped.
She was kind of drunk.
Yeah.
She was like,
we're going to go do it now.
And I was gross grows.
Remember this here
video in a while,
but I know make up to make it up to you.
Because this year I've come up with something called the super and Super Burp is
where I saw it on a lot of air.
I wait till it six done more air because it makes her up instead of just barfing
up right up right away.
So give me a little bit,
be patient.
It's really painful to them.
So why are we watching the secret?
I don't know because I just fucking found it.
Oh.
I thought there was a purpose.
There is a purpose to watch it.
Oh,
what do you mean
she's the burp champ?
It's hard to watch this part.
That's why
I like
to use that for one of your promos for stand that Facebook is taking them down.
You know,
ball.
Those assholes are taking them down.
They're making it so that,
uh,
justice,
yeah.
You know,
I don't like that clip because it's like she's vomiting in the beginning.
I don't like that.
You think so?
I'll just like the burping part.
I don't like the vomity stuff.
Yeah.
I don't feel like it's that
you don't because you don't have a sensitivity to it.
I do.
Yeah.
But you shouldn't.
Yeah,
I know that it's mental problem.
I know that we've covered that.
You're the psychology champ already.
I have fucking problems with things that most people don't.
Can we irrational problems with things?
I know that.
Can we change it?
I've talked about it with my shrink a few times.
It's gotten better as it,
how so?
Well,
I'm a little like,
when baby jeans throws up,
I don't go into a full panic.
Oh yeah.
That's all I really care about is how I react around him,
you know,
cause I don't want him to get weird.
Yeah.
So that's gotten better.
Good.
So it sounds like progress.
Yeah,
but I don't,
if I don't have to see it,
I don't want to,
you know.
Alright.
Um,
alright.
We should go.
Um,
there was a lot of fun.
Thank you guys for listening as always.
A go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Tom's [inaudible] dot com thousand ranch.com.
Anything else,
Jean?
I'm hungry.
I'm hungry too.
This is a,
uh,
it's called Ultra humongous whale penis.
Call Gaping Dad.
I love that is always dropping the hit gaping.
Dad's crushing the song game.
It really is.
Thank you guys.
Thanks genes.
We'll see a little while.
Jean.
Oh,
sorry.
Can you hold for a second?
God,
that is massive.
This is a whale's penis.
God,
that is massive
animal.
Hello.
You love the penis.
He's actually,
this is the cheap holding a penis.
No bone in his penis.
It's completely flexible.
This penis is pretend style.
God.
That is massive.
God,
that is massive.
Poultry,
poultry,
poultry.
You'll few fungus,
fungus.
Amungus.
You found a spot
to fund to.
We have to stop.
We haven't gotten together this whale off the beach or you finished it and know?
Yes.
Unbelievable.
That is massive.
It's massive.
It's actually probably the most amazing penis in the animal world.
There was no phone in his penis is completely flipped.